hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to rust with my good friend
Bob hey guys he's actually right there
like he's right there
hey kid how do I maybe it's better if I
go in yours Hey so anyway yeah we're in
the same room we've ended up for the
holidays we decided to get together and
play some video games and this one is um
he was jealous of me playing with weight
on seven days to die so this is another
kind of like crafting survival type game
as you can see use this shirtless
handsome devil in front of me and we
have some very meager supplies obviously
no clothes but it's an early alpha but
from always seeing so far it looks
really really interesting so it's I like
the gun rocks yeah the gun rocks on
science in alpha so some things are a
little bit funky on it but either way
we're gonna try this our best now Wade
isn't here honest Lee so we probably
don't know what we're doing
no no no we don't have that person who
understands the mechanics of the game
yeah yeah and the only reason we did in
the first place was because he had
zombie with him and zombie always
another thing but I do know that you hit
fries with rocks to get wood as per use
as per usual most everything that is any
sort of really big freakin tree thank
you I know isn't it can we both can we
both hit it at the same time oh I'm sure
I'd be delighted
it's my tree wait Bob wait don't be I
apologize the horrible insult of calling
you I'm so sorry for that but either way
you just confuse the only one you ever
invite to play these games I can't help
with the yeren north to Alania i we yeah
yes well actually now that you're done
with law school temporarily like you'll
have more time it's see oh there's no
wood left here apparently okay excuse me
are you sure wait do that again says can
you get what other thing cuz when I hit
it it says there's no wood love let me
try
okay yeah there's no one left in this
tree well oh my god this is gonna be
awesome
oh it's gonna be so good okay I'm
already like pretty hurting on food
though oh can we get food um we get food
bye
yes we am no kill animals with our bare
hands well you can use your bare hands
I'm gonna use this lovely rock that I
was providing the beginning of the game
I so how does this crap how how do I
open the crafting thing and you press
tab and that'll open like your inventory
armor and you get blink furnaces yeah I
don't know much about the furnaces but I
know that's it yeah there's like metal
and stuff in this game but over down if
you look down this hill there are some
am animals over there we're doing we
need like we should get us some sort of
hatchet or something first where'd you
go I'm Sam up here I'm by this tree what
tree I see you standing over there
jumping around like a [ __ ]
hey what up where we were up I am where
are you I'm right by the tree up the
hill from the tree that's out over there
you little dot over in the distance you
didn't see me you're dying you were
running around on top of these rail
lying okay never mind you know what can
we get can you only get rocks from
certain rocks or what what's wrong with
this I don't know I get rocks no these
are just I think these are just
landmarks what we need to do is we need
to go down the hill number one get food
number two worried about rocks later I
don't know anything I want to hatch it I
want it for you I don't have a hatchet
they want to really like that book
what's it called the jungle book no uh
Tale of Two Cities
oh I just broke my legs hatchet that was
a movie I was a book oh that was a book
how did did you not ever do fifth
graders oh oh cheese me some Big Bob
went to grade school Wow some of us
didn't I made it all the way L dude
these are not food animals not are they
these are wolves what so you eat a wolf
they're gonna murder us how wait I with
their wolf teeth I just need to patch
myself up apparently wait did I do oh
dude you get so much wood from these
random piles of wood over here well
that's convenient how these piles of
wood are here thank god someone pile all
this wood up so I can tell
by hitting it with my rock damn 7 why
didn't we even bother with the trees
yeah apparently a tree is a big-ass
waste of time oh oh you you gathered
that pile I'll gather this what's
gathered oh it's all done okay help me
gather my piles smash your roll I can't
touch your wood it's oh there we go
yeah thank you my wood it's very elusive
Beast survival games open up the door
for so many wood books like yeah how can
you not make those jokes it's minecraft
that started it all okay 117 we have no
choice now
wow oh my god there's another horrible
sounding listen to the thunk on that
[ __ ] oh we got oh look at it I got
cloth oh don't hit me I didn't hit you
oh the health thing does for bleeding
yeah if I'm bleak cuz I took most no
shoot yeah you didn't do any damage to
me what are you doing that wall
I gave me a bunch of raw chicken breasts
apparently really I got four raw chicken
breasts and some an old fat and
apparently this wolf was wearing some
clothes cuz I'm getting a bunch of cloth
oh good
no I got some cloth - wait a minute what
can I don't think these developers are
clear on what animals are made of
everything every animal is made of
chicken chicken just means meat from an
animal you know you know what that means
is this is like the matric and the guy
said the robots didn't know what you
into so they made everything tastes like
chicken
there you go honestly if that's what
they were going for that is the best
reference that's ever been made well
that would be far too acute actually be
something I need to think how oh how in
the crap well wait well whoa crafting is
interesting how do I yeah this is a
weird list where's the food well I think
you'd wait no you need to make a
campfire to cook the food I think that
would at least all man's okay so well I
can do a campfire
are you crafting a campfire know how
much dad I can't partake five five a
hundred and seventeen wood oh my god
well not certain for wood yeah yo it
takes time that takes time to craft -
I'm gonna make a wood shelter because
I'm assuming that's what we need no wait
can I you can craft the wood shelter
yeah it's just in here there's a whole
list in here Oh
do that I'm doing it to Hamid I'm doing
it okay right now
hey my campfires done I just need to
have somewhere to place it now I got
hang on I'm gonna build a shelter you're
gonna put a run from the shelf it will
be beautiful in in front of Ryan not Ian
it would burn to the ground
it's okay maybe maybe not I don't know I
mean - is this how how much like
minecraft do you think this is do we
have to light the house with torches or
well the torches have limits though a -
like it's is 249 I mean place this torch
down I don't think so I'm like I'm in
the ground it's not working so I mister
whoa whoa holy crap look at no look at
me you seen that I see that holy
okay I'm gonna nestled it in these rocks
over here okay we're gonna live all snug
as a bug in a rug and lugging her jugs
of jugs are chunks of snug bug I don't
know kind of slanted butt-dialed ooh so
do we need to construct some sort of
door for this yeah wait a minute no I
saw a door there was a door yeah well
let me [ __ ] I gotta Thor can't fire
outside
are you sure inside I don't know outside
of course you wouldn't put it inside
what do you don't you know what smokey
the borer said smokey the board I give
up the water with smokey the boars work
no it was it smokey the Borg you know
after he became assimilated you know he
kind of his message still stuck with me
don't worry very additional use I want
to use yeah there we go you used it how
did you oh wait no God take the chicken
in your inventory hold it in your hand
use it on the thing I okay just do it
just do it
Oh God cuz it oh my god good what would
you do III whoa I ate it
Oh oh my god I just threw up horse like
that has ever happened to me I think I
have salmonella what up you know though
my god I'm throwing I dunno how I got
this horrifying
oh that and give me a piece Oh
I want the viewers out there to
experience oh I'm gonna throw up
I guess they're dead you're my crack and
split it okay give me one I want the
viewers drop someone on the green yeah
okay take raw chicken breast
when Fidel was horrifying okay I'm
poison Oh waiting and I turned up your
mic wha Oh God I told you now that's bad
it's bad it's bad right so I turned
we're gonna look at your mic mister the
home like you're fine and then I turned
you up and we Revere that I'm gonna
equalize the crap out of it I like look
at the fire you can turn the fire on and
off mmm okay I didn't know fires worked
like that but so I turned it on and now
I wanna now I want to make chickens okay
how do I chickens I don't know but we're
about to die of starvation
our first night is not going not to
chicken breast so how do I chickens oh
no one that you obviously don't use it
it can make 9-millimeter em oh no I
don't need that how can you make
9-millimeter ammo there's no how do I
make food I sent ahead I have blood is
it your own blood
no it's backs of blood which I
apparently collected from the wolf I
want to you know food I don't fire I was
like drop it in the now if i push the oh
not that dude I do not know I'm gonna go
try to find it out it's not to my Killa
well but it's just cuz its rod its rod
yes raw I show how do I unroll it
oh no I'm new to this game can I just
throw it at the fire while you try I'm
cold now why am i cold cold and hungry
I'm dying
why wait really needs to be here to help
us cuz we're not doing well can i make
like you can't make us dirt uh oh that's
right I I have enough cloth to make a
sleeping bag yeah wait would that do us
I have no idea we need a lot of closet
below or while we're standing around
like morons so at least no no no no no
no I have a wood door I made that I made
that I made that cancels apparently you
can craft and not look at the crafting
screens the same
I'm oh I can make low-grade fuel what is
that what good would that do us
I don't know we could burn it or
something I can make up oh I can make a
work oh I can't make a work we can
destroy the only home that we have just
for your amusement hell yeah let's do it
OOP I got it whoa yeah cool huh the
door's locked
oh sorry I put it there I can't we need
it we need a house um two doors oh crap
well I guess they wanted to make it
secure because it's a server with other
people on it I mean of course it's gonna
be like troubles them Oh just sewing
today if you stand around the campfire
it warms you up
also if you stand in the campfire you
don't burn oh look at that
that's a little on me huh oh well you
know you do it can they can't see what
you're doing am I in it yeah you're in
it that's really offensive I assume I
have Americans I don't know well I
didn't even think it was about that
until well apparently Bob hates Native
Americans you hate me who knew this Oh
fun my god make everything offensive god
that's how the hell do I cook this damn
chicken huh you know what do I need a
pot or something I don't know to make it
cooking okay sack and let's think about
this spike wall and let's take a lot of
wood I can make a spike wall hang on
let's think about this what if a furnace
what about a furnace could you put the
chicken in the furnace cuz in like
Minecraft you put the chicken in the
furnace with fuel you got things oh it
worked
do you have a how do we make a furnace
need stone I saw you need a stone
low-grade fuel that's what we needed for
that okay well I can craft the low-grade
fuel I'm gonna go look for stone I'll
stand here and do nothing I'm assuming
that stone would be obvious when I saw
it otherwise what's the point I guess I
should probably come with you no I'm
good I'm about to starve to death anyway
so it don't matter it don't matter it
don't I wouldn't figure maybe you should
make a sleeping bag before you go and
you know
that set the spot or something no I'm
gonna do that no baby I don't know I'm
gonna say I'm going that's why cuz when
you died that time it says respawn at
camp behind the scenes we're trying it
out you trying to find me
anyone's not able to find me you got
killed by like a wolf in a zombie long
way to meet one more cloth to make us I
got cloth leading them coming I'm coming
baby I'm coming I got the clot getting
dark and very comfortable here even
though I'm dying of hunger slowly shut
up I also have two low-grade fuel oh
very nice you need like eat what you
make you I all you need this animal fat
and cloth that's why I don't have enough
for the aisle I need where are you oh
yeah okay so how do I you just like
click it out of here I'll get it right
yeah wow it looks like a sack of money
that's how a cloth Miss looks like it's
a cloth bag with one piece of cloth in
it whatever oh why can't I use the cloth
trumpet why do we keep so many clock
bags around for this odd we just needed
to transport all of our goodies
even the cloth I don't like holding
cloth it needs to be inside a cloth bag
and chicken wolf all right so I'm gonna
put the sleeping bag in here I assume
you think but now it's gonna be really
dark in here if you close that door oh
ok so bad we still get the comfort from
the fire to it you should we'll burn
whatever apparently we can do people a
comfort thing on the bottom right yeah I
see no is so he's still in here so let's
I don't know if if my sleeping bag is
just for me they were like well you put
it down it'll probably be just for you I
mean I don't think that we could cuddle
in it
where'd it go oh there it is pick up oh
it's like you placed it it's like good
that's um that's not helpful
what's the point how do you use it is
there some button that we're not getting
here no I I'm pretty sure he is the use
button no something besides to use
button there's got to be something else
like there's just got to be uh what was
that
what did you hear something what oh my
god wait heard you I was pushing v push
it down
Oh what happens now what happened we
know hello
oh yeah are we talking to everyone on
this server well I think we're just
talking to people in the local area they
were like like just between anyone here
s1 here uh anyone out there anyone out
there we call to the heaven save us was
a black-and-white reference case anyone
else actually miss radio on every
morning all right anyway so I know can't
fire why'd you turn off because it's
probably out of would occupy its
occupied by no way but you can cook get
off it
get off the guy I see a mustache see I
see it off I am off I stole what he was
talking about we're good bang holy crap
we can make charcoal and oh I'm dying
hunger I'm gonna make some uh big food
like right now cuz I'm dying
okay uh how do I make it make the food I
don't know put it in there it's in there
that's what it was wooden the thing and
I'll turn it on the fire needs to be
like lit the fires not lit how do you
like the fire uh take the charcoal out
put the [ __ ] put wood in no that's just
that's the well alright you know what
I'm just gonna make another campfire
because apparently you don't know how to
play this game okay turn it I got 20
seconds to make another campfire I hope
I don't starve to death before then I
sincerely hope that I do I put it on the
fire now how do I make the fires not on
how do I make it be your wooden both the
things and now that oh no I don't know I
got another one cooking in like here we
go I'm gonna put this here and boom I'm
a turn-on yeah now use that hang on all
my chicken is sitting on this but I
don't know how do you do how do you make
it do the thing that does that I don't
understand again East and wait wait wait
what
you know nothing nothing nothing no
nothing nothing at all nothing is
nothing
no okay we're gonna die so the Sun has
set on our final chance looks like this
chapter has come to a close we die let's
see what happens if I just leave the
chick in there and and go go to bed
overnight and see what happens in the
morning oh you started the fire how with
Mike Lawrence your torch yeah oh no but
the chickens just in it oh I don't know
how do we get the chicken out I don't
know good ask me
I love their torch out of here hi all
right fine jeez oh my god we have to let
it cook that whole time what time it's
gonna just go now forever apparently
until it's done like it turned itself
the fire stopped before when we left it
and so now it's just gonna cook until it
stops cooking and then the chickens done
cooking when it's done cooking ah stupid
this game is open I there's gotta be a
better way clapping there's got to be
but then again guys we don't know what
the hell we're doing do you have any
more cloth is that oh not know I gave
you my whole burlap sack of cloth pick
up this you know should be saving up
David we're all out of time for this one
we're the next one we're dead this is
our death I can't do any more progress
go anyway thank you all so much for
watching if you liked this game and want
us to play more cuz I'm sure it's much
deeper than what we've seen so far sir
it's more than two campfires than a
wooden shack yeah but we are gonna play
more while Bob is here so I don't
doesn't really matter if you want to see
any more anyway cuz you're gonna see
more so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation more
videos that I've done thanks Bob Murphy
late and I was stealing all your iron
blocks
that didn't work out okay Donner [ __ ]
understand that's cooking I don't know
the penalties to what's happening you
know anything you do all right
I really I think it is like the fire
it's like a fire cycle yeah cuz when you
turn it off and then sleep there's got
to be another used button that we're not
I'm just gonna look on the wiki and see
about ki guess